in the last video we talked about with
the beginnings of JPEGs so what do we do
at the beginning of the process to start
preparing for the discrete cosine
transform which is really how the lossy
compression happens within a JPEG
compressed file so we start with our RGB
image we convert that into the ycbcr
color space which separates for
luminance and the chrominance and then
we can down sample the chrominance if we
want and we can kind of get away with
quite a bit of down sampling there but
people won't be able to see the next
step is the discrete cosine transform
before we start talking about how images
are compressed using discrete cosine
transform it's much better just to start
with a simple example of what a discrete
cosine transform is and how it works a
cosine function for anyone that isn't
familiar with it is a function that goes
between 1 and minus 1 what we tend to do
on this on this x-axis is go from naught
to PI to 2 pi this is in radians those
of you familiar with degrees this is 180
degrees at pi and 360 degrees at 2pi and
the cosine wave looks like this so it's
1 at 0 and then at pi it goes down to
minus 1 and when it goes back up to 1 at
2pi and it just goes on and on like this
up and down if you increase the waiver
to discrete cosine transform works is we
take some data in this case our image
data and we try and represent it as the
sum of lots of these waves which doesn't
make a lot of sense until you start
drawing them out so let's imagine that
we've got this cosine wave here which is
our standard frequency cosine wave and
then we've got another cosine wave which
is a much higher frequency so that will
be come down a bit faster go up a bit
faster come down a bit faster and go a
bit faster like this ok so now we have
two waves if we add them together what
we get is a sort of another wave which
is a combination of the two so if we
draw it in here in this dashed line we
can see halfway between these two waves
is like this and then kind of like this
and you can see that we've created
another more complex shaped wave by
adding these two together now as we
increase the number of cosines we can
increase the number of possible shapes
of ways that we can produce in practice
if we added these two ways together we'd
have a way that was much taller than the
input so here it would be 2 not 1 so
what in fact we do is we way
both of these and so we take an average
so both of these are weighted in this
case as a 1/2 and so this is essentially
the average of both of them we could
also change the weighting of these so we
could have it was mostly this
high-frequency one but only a little bit
of this low-frequency one and we'd have
a different shaped wave coming out the
end so each wave represents a small
constituent of the the output and the
higher the frequency of the wave the
higher frequency part of the signal
we're dealing with so if we look at my
my jumper here there's a low frequency
change from this black table to a
brightness right over my jumper to
darktable again and as much higher
frequency changes on my jumper where we
go up and down within sort of the woolen
knit and it's the same kind of principle
we're arguing in JPEG that we can get
rid of some of the higher frequency
signals and the general gist of the
image will still be there so this is
just a one-dimensional discrete cosine
transform with only two components the
way that the the mathematics works is if
we have a signal that's 8 long then we
find that we can represent it using 8
cosine waves of different frequencies
and the same is true of an image what we
do in JPEG is we split each image into 8
by 8 pixel groups and each of those
pixel groups is separately encoded with
its own discrete cosine transform each
of those 8 by 8 pixel groups can be
exactly replicated by 64 so 8 by 8
cosine waves this actually shows the 64
base cosine waves that produce any image
we might like to do in 8 by 8 pixels
this particular component here is
essentially flat okay so if you had only
this component and that was all that
contributed to your final output your
image would look like that okay if you
had only this one your image would go
white and then it would dip down and go
black and you can see that the frequency
is increasing as we go along here this
is in the X direction and then in the Y
direction the frequency is increasing
down here so this is a cosine wave and
this is a higher frequency cosine wave
down here as we increase the frequency
in both directions we get a kind of
checkerboard pattern if this is a high
frequency information that we're
encoding in these regions so these are
v60 for cosine functions that can be
combined to make any 8x8 image
it is only in one channel so let's say
just you luminance or just CR for
example if we had half of this wave and
half of this wave then what you get is a
square of image that was generally
brighter on the left with a little bit
of light on the right hand side because
you've samba two together to create any
kind of 8x8 image what we need to do is
have a combination of all of these at
the same time each of these is weighted
based on something called a coefficient
which represents is a number
representing the contribution of each of
these individual blocks to the whole so
for example if the contribution of this
one is zero then there is no part of
this cosine wave in the in the 8x8 image
that we're looking at if it's a naught
point one and this one's ten then this
is obviously got a hundred fold less
impact on your output image than this
one and what we do with discrete cosine
transform is basically calculate the
coefficients for these waves putting
this discrete cosine transform aside for
a minute if we just look at an example
image so this is a small crop section of
our flower image this is the Y component
so it's just every value from naught to
255 how intense is the pixel so you can
see this is not a hugely interesting
piece of image it's kind of gray with a
little bit of brighter region down here
what we want to try and do is calculate
the contribution of each of our cosine
waves to this image which bits of cosine
do we need that add together to create
an image that looks exactly like this so
to start with what we need to do is
Center all of these values which are
currently centered around 128 because
they're from naught to 255 we sent all
these values around zero because
remember a cosine wave goes from 1 to
minus 1 not from 1 to naught so we take
away 128 of every value and we get our
shifted block like this so this is the
exact same image but this time now
centered around 0 and now we can use
this in the discrete cosine transform to
calculate our coefficients we apply the
it's actually discrete cosine transform
number 2 which is the ones always using
jpg and what that does is calculate the
contribution of each of our cosine waves
that when added together will create
this image exactly right which of these
blocks when multiplied by their
coefficients to tell us how much of each
one we use will add together to create
this exact image so it might be a bit of
a bit of this yeah a lot of that yeah
and none of this one exactly and so
you'll find that all of these will have
some impact on the image it's almost
certain unless the image is completely
flat one of the nice things about JPEG
is these low frequency ones will have a
much bigger effect from the high
frequency data and we also see them
better so that's how we we compress JPEG
so we calculate our DCT two coefficients
and that gives us some slightly
arbitrary values between minus 1024 and
plus 1024 but that's not too much of a
big problem and what we have each of
these represents the weight or the
amount of each of our cosine wave so if
we put this next to here we can say that
if we take this cosine and multiply it
by minus 370 and add it to this one
multiplied by twenty nine point seven
and so on and we do it for all of them
the added sum will be our original image
back again usually this top left
coefficient is much bigger than the
others because this is because it's a
flat and it's actually flat and not a
cosine wave represents the general
intensity of that particular image block
so this is called our direct current
coefficient or DC coefficient all of the
others are alternating current AC
coefficients in practice usually the DC
coefficients are stored separately but
we you know we won't we won't dwell on
that too much the really important
aspect of JPEG that you need you want to
understand is that these coefficients
are often very very small and these ones
are very very big and what that tells us
is that the high frequency cosine waves
don't really contribute very much to the
image for example this one is zero which
means that this cosine wave here is
having no effect on the image at all the
image is essentially not a checkerboard
in any way these ones compared to these
big coefficients here are incredibly
small as well and have very subtle
effects on the actual output pixel data
I mean these weights are so small but if
you took these away the image will be
almost identical and yet we could just
take them away and save all that space
so that's how we do it for next step
after calculating our discrete cosine
transform coefficients is basically try
and remove the ones we don't want we
call the process of removing the high
frequency data quantization hopefully
it'd be easier if I show you a
quantization table this is the standard
JPEG quantization table that represents
a quality of fifty percent so in a JPEG
standard different compressors like the
one used in Photoshop will use different
quantization
depending on how they feel and also what
level of quality you set it out and what
we do is we divide every one of our
coefficients by the corresponding
quantization value and then round to the
nearest integer okay
and you can see already but these ones
are much bigger than these ones so what
essentially happens is these get scaled
by a huge amount usually too close to
zero and then get removed by being set
to zero when we round to the nearest
integer so for example 370 divided by 16
is roughly 23 or minus 23 and the actual
quantized output is this and you can see
but almost all of it's now zero so this
coefficient now no longer has an effect
nor does this one or this one the only
ones that have any effect on our image
are these 9 here and essentially the
argument that we're making is that with
just these 9 we can get pretty much the
exact same image back he won't be
exactly the same that a couple of pixels
will be maybe an intensity level up or
down but when viewed at a normal image
range you know let's say a photograph or
on a monitor it'll look exactly the same
to us so what we then finally do when we
want to output this information into our
file is we essentially list all these in
a long line we then use a Huffman
encoding which for the Belfort is
covered in a video to further compress
this data the way that we serialize this
into our file is in a zigzag fashion so
we start with minus 23 then we go minus
2 minus 21 so we're going up and down up
and down 6 4 0 0 2 1 and so on and the
important thing about this is by doing
this we're going to get a huge list of
noughts all in a row and that is very
easily compressed by Huffman encoding so
we take this table we do this for every
8 by 8 block in our image we vent
serialize them out into a long line and
we use Huffman encoding to shrink them
right down and that's what goes into our
jpg and in all other aspects of JPEG a
really sort of minor format
considerations that's the core of how
the compression works to decompress the
image let's imagine that we've we send
our jpg to someone and they're decode
was trying to read it what we have to do
is the exact opposite of this approach
so we begin by multiplying each of these
values by our quantization table so this
is the same quantization table it's
stored inside the JPEG so we know which
one they you
because if you use a different one on
the way out you're going to ruin your
image so we multiply each of these
values by the specific value in the
quantization table and we get the
coefficients and you can see that
because most of them are nought most of
them on the other side will also not so
none of these are going to contribute to
our image anymore then in reverse we use
discrete cosine transform number three
which is usually just call be the
inverse discrete cosine transform
because it's generally used to inverse
what we did for discrete cosine
transform two and that gives us our
shifted block back again which of course
we then add 198 to every value and we
have our output block and there it is so
that's the complete JPEG compression
using discrete cosine transform if we
look at our input block and our output
block next to each other so there we go
we can see that there are some changes
in these values but it's actually pretty
close these are sort of change of
Krista's gone up a few intensity levels
this is the same this has gone down for
but these are for naught to 255 no one's
going to see that kind of difference and
this is a 50% so you can do a lot less
than this if you have your JPEG quality
set higher and smaller values in your
quantization table so in the JPEG
standard this is the quantization table
they give you this is actually the
quantization table for luminosity not
for chrominance they have a different
one for chromatids which is much has
much higher penalties on the high
frequency because if high frequency data
is not very important in gray it's even
less important given that we don't see
color that well one thing you can do to
immediately increase the quality of oval
JPEG compression day is preserve as much
image as possible is to have all of
these values in a quantization table if
we divide all of these values by 2 then
essentially everything is being scaled
by less all of these high frequency
coefficients won't necessarily be
rounded to 0 they might be rounded to
one or two and they'll still have a
little bit of an effect on the other
hand if we increase the values in these
quantization tables we're essentially
operating a lower JPEG quality setting
this is the approach that the JPEG
standard uses in other software they may
have their own quantization tables in
fact as far as I know Photoshop I think
they have 12 quality settings and they
have different quantization tables for
most of both settings and different
sampling frequencies so lots of
different things that they've decided
make for pretty good scale bar but a
user
News and all of those settings are then
stored in the header of the file yeah
between these parties you'll get a small
block that says these are the
quantization tables and Huffman coding
tables that we used so that everyone can
reverse that process if you don't know
what the quantization table was you
might be multiplying your encoded
coefficients by different values and get
something completely different out at
the end
what will it be just different colors it
could be a completely different image
you've divided by certain numbers you
need to multiply again by those numbers
to inverse the process otherwise you
might get nonsense back out so going
back to the original diagram that I drew
this is sort of the overview of JPEG we
start with our image we've transformed
our color and then our DCT essentially
removes the high frequency information
in our image so if we've got an image
where lots of high frequency information
high frequency pixel changes are
happening that might get significantly
compressed but it might also look worse
okay but if but in most photographs
certainly over an 8 by 8 image block you
won't be finding that much higher
frequency information and so we can
quite safely get rid of a lot of it we
calculate our DCT coefficients we
quantize them to remove the high
frequency ones and then we use Huffman
encoding to compress that into a
manageable small stream that we put into
our JPEG file and then the reverse of
that process is exactly that we decode
the Huffman tables the Huffman encoding
we unquantifiable all our values in the
quantization table and then we apply the
inverse dct to obtain our block back and
we do this for every little 8x8 image in
our in our picture if our image isn't a
multiple of 8 then we have to add some
padding bytes at the end to make it work
usually we could duplicate the ones near
the edge so but it kind of has this
coherent or you might do something a
little bit smarter text violates our
assumptions that high frequency
information doesn't contribute a lot to
the image so this is a small 8 by 8
image this is in a sent text this is V
computer file see it's little triangular
brackets